okay so this is for you a bunch of
people have been sending this in
the vp of nike here
in northern america had to resign
because they found out that her son
has been ordering shoes with the credit
card that he set up in her name using
her
employee uh connections he would buy
hundreds and hundreds of sneakers then
resell them do you know how much
money this kid was making here's what's
the [ __ ] about this you know uh
ann herbert who was the who worked for
uh nike
you know she's making like three four
million a year like i don't know why she
did this
but i'm confused so was he actually
getting shoes
from official nike or was he just buying
mikey's yeah but was he using her
discount yes
like oh wow yes so uh the story
officially as of now
is that she resigned uh she resigned
shortly after they found out because he
was actually
having an interview done with a popular
like shoe publication
and he ended up speaking a little too
loosely
and he revealed who his mom was when
they started fishing into
who like how he got off his connections
they realized that she's been working
for nike for 25 years so he snitched on
himself
yeah he basically snitched on himself
well this is obvious he wasn't he didn't
move smart either he had
six pairs of nike mags yes you know
he was very very vocal about how he has
all these shoes
and he's like the plug he was loud about
it yeah he was very loud about it but
nobody knew who
his mom was they didn't know how he was
getting these shoots and so when he did
the interview he accidentally
outed his mom and then he tried to get
the publication to not publish her name
and his connections
they then found out that he actually
signed up for a credit card under his
mother's name
and then used her name her connections
and all the information
he knows about her work stuff to then
get these shoes he would get
hundreds and hundreds he spent 132 grand
one morning for a launch of kanye west
sneakers
how long did this go on for a few years
he is currently
19 so we don't know exactly how long
he's been doing this for well
i wanted to face for a reason why i'm
taking hills on this nike app
everyone's so mad i never went on that
sneaker app
from somebody else from a plug or
something like that i take so many l's
on that [ __ ]
oh
19 like there's no like how do you but
if you have all your access to your
mom's like
yeah but at some point when that person
the supplier who's giving you should be
like wait a [ __ ] minute
yes how come he was never going back to
nike like yo they're doing it yeah
there's a few people like
you you know why does jeremy want eight
nike mags
yeah shoot that soldier he could he
could have been he could have been
paying them off
yeah there's there's other people there
i don't know there's other people yeah
but also that mom was making
four million a year yeah so she had the
responsibility
to resign yeah it's terrible people
think that she reside
she resigns so quickly and so quietly
because there's more that will come out
that she's worried they're gonna find
out because people are speculating that
like when she found out she was just
like oh i'm
sorry like my son did this it's wrong
but i'm gonna step down for the
better of the company people think that
she's trying to cover up something else
like maybe he did something else even
worse with all of her information
for nike so it's still there's an
investigation going on but
damn well hopefully this means i'll win
shoes next week
and this week we should pray what else
you have
okay so um a oregon
judge has recently ruled that miss
america
the actual pageant competition can now
say that only natural born females are
able to be in the pageant
because there was a transgender uh
beauty queen in oregon who wanted to
then
compete to eventually try to compete for
the title she's prettier than these
natural born women who gives a [ __ ] uh
like if it's that girl from vegas stevie
showed up
sounds like something she'd have to go
do like a lot more yeah
dude she was born a dude and then you
know she's just crashing down she
becomes miss america i mean
uh i think you can find it i don't have
it in this article
i need to know that that's where she
should be she she may not be bad
it looks like me with
miss oregon
i don't think she was actually miss
oregon she was miss earth oregon it's
like a different
beauty pageant so like miss oregon but
not really oh [ __ ]
beauty pad yeah what are they so worried
about yeah well she wanted to compete
and so the organization actually saw her
she ain't getting away
china ass over there yeah
it's fine she ain't gonna win
let her
zoo culture what else you got jen
okay as you were saying
you always both see that
as you're saying texas uh yesterday
officially announced that they
are 100 open and that there is no longer
going to be a mass mandate now don't get
it twisted it's not like if you fly to
texas right now it's off and pop
everyone's masses off yeah because all
the mayors you know can decide
like austin's hey tell you austin ain't
open
so they can dictate if they're gonna the
state might say hey you don't have to
enforce anything
but yeah each mayor can decide so the
mayor in austin's like nope
we're still using mass we're still half
capacity you can eat inside
so it's not like people think it's just
like oh it's it's popping now it's not
especially in austin got it as i go
there this weekend
but it's still better than here yeah
yeah 100
all right so there is a company who is
starting to
uh plan the creation of the first
space hotel and it's they're planning on
opening it up
for 2027 anywhere between a
three-day weekend two weekly rentals
monthly you can go to spaces or you can
buy six years yeah or you can buy um
like a a room there how do you get there
a plane a spaceship a spaceship and then
you dock and then you get
[ __ ] up doing that that [ __ ] lit
hell yeah i'll do that no absolutely not
would you pros cons
you ever been to four seasons in hawaii
yeah i don't need to go to [ __ ] mars
to hang out
i can look down at hawaii at least a few
weeks
ago it really depends on how far
the hotel is going to be well no if it's
just if it's just like floating in
orbit yeah because mars takes
[ __ ] forever yeah that's why i don't
know if it's six months a few days a few
weeks or if it's gonna be months
as of right now i don't think they're
taking you like way deep into space but
also you know how
it's like even if you get to hawaii you
got an oceanfront property
like oh damn this is great look at that
beach and then you move on with your
life
you would fly all the way to space all
these
[ __ ] variables then you get there
you're like damn look at the earth from
here like they're just in the room
bro you and you're like i want to go
and then some dumb ass like opens up a
window or something and we all get
sucked out
that's happened now [ __ ]
you know something right you see people
on cruise ships all the time they fall
off the side
you have that idiot yeah it's hot
there's so much stuff i haven't seen
here on in that's true yeah that is true
yeah
i've never been to thailand [ __ ] mom
i heard thailand's friends food oh my
god ladyboys
yeah i want to go to thailand eat the
food yeah
i saw it on korea japan they have great
fashion in japan the mario kart uh
kids yeah damn there's so many places so
many places to go yeah
i'm all set on space we don't have time
right now we'll have time to go
everywhere we want to go here
yeah so why go there why did i go to
school yeah i'm just
all right all right well you guys talk
i'm up there you guys talked off there
about this but jj watt signing with the
uh
cardinals yeah and then uh i guess
yesterday he signed a two
two year deal for like 31 or potentially
31 million dollars good for him man
two years two years yeah two year deals
wow i think he has like two years left
you know yeah when uh i don't know but
three-time
uh defense player of the year he's a
beast man especially
oh he's still he's only 31. he's bradley
what is that uh in football it's getting
up there
years oh really yeah yeah but he still
has some good time left there's a reason
for his position yeah yeah but he's just
been injure
injury yeah and that defensive line i
can't think of that guy name he's gonna
be the
opposite side of him they're gonna have
a good squad next year arizona
yeah all right all right you gotta get
my arizona yeah
uh this is an mma one so hamza shamayev
he's like one of the
the more famous up-and-comers he's
pretty brand new right he's killing it
right now he got he got hot last year
because he took i think
like four fights and like yeah short
span
some [ __ ] like fought you kept fighting
kept fighting and winning star
awesome fashion too yeah he was he was
he was like the
mvp of covet fighting like he kept
fighting kept fighting and beating the
shot why is it why is he done
so he'd had kovid and apparently like he
tried many times to like fight it but
then
he's still getting like residual effects
from it so here's what so
so he had covered pulled out of he's
supposed to fight leon edwards
um he they kept postponing the fight he
got kovit
had horrible symptoms from it you know
he's one of the poor guys that have
horrible symptoms
but then they put him this is dana white
speaking yeah for this
they put him on the steroid to help him
with his lung stuff and i apparently
it's some crazy steroid that has
horrible like effects like side effects
and they told him don't work out on it
dude you're gonna feel like [ __ ] but
it's gonna beat this thing
so eventually it can work out obviously
he didn't listen
gets that shot and then tries working
out the next day and felt horrible
so he's like oh this is how i'm going to
feel i retire he got here on twitter i
was like oh
i retire i can't fight anymore but
apparently him and dana had a
conversation
and danny's like he's not retiring he's
emotional he'll be fine so he posted on
his instagram how
he just his body's not working the way
the right way because the illness so
he's he feels like he has to leave the
sport
and then dana and i talk to him and also
hamza ramzan khadirov who has like a
crazy history
in chechnya uh he had to talk with him
and then he immediately says i'm back
i think he's just emotionally how it is
you know
he's a monster and then he goes to the
gym and everything's slow and he feels
[ __ ] he's like i can't beat anybody like
this so
yeah he just kind of he's also young so
you got emotional how long is this this
like
does this last like covet stuff like
does that because i was reading stuff
about some people get it like it lasts a
while
yeah i think everyone's different man
you think you know a guy who's in good
shape and stuff he'd beat it fast but
apparently it was really bad for him i
don't know if he had
other issues stuff like that you know if
he had pneumonia as a kid
there's a bunch of stuff that goes into
it yeah
but yeah he'll be all right he just got
you don't know when he first got up it
was probably like a month or two ago
yeah when he got it yeah when he got it
oh and he's been fighting it ever since
oh so it's recent yeah yeah it's already
set yeah give him some time just like a
month ago he just
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah he'll be fine
guarantee he fights again
all right uh bill burr talking about
gina carano's firing
yeah i heard about this you saw that
yeah yeah yeah
he was on another party it's a weird
timeless she did some truly horrible
[ __ ] or said
overly racist [ __ ] uh i don't know i
think there's just too many channels and
then
you gotta do sensational [ __ ] i don't
know what the [ __ ] it is
i'm on that [ __ ] show now i gotta
watch the he's just being super honest
about it too yeah she was an absolute
sweetheart i love bilber she was an
absolute sweetheart super [ __ ]
super nice [ __ ] a lot of cussing
super nice
uh you know whatever and some how
someone will take this video and they'll
make me say something else and try to
get rid of
my bald action figure it's
[ __ ] crazy times people just waiting
laying in the weeds doug
yeah yeah uh keep going down later in
the podcast
elaborate on his views uh canceled
culture saying now it's becoming like
hey you made an ignorant comparison
uh there goes your dream right and i
look at this and it's like who the [ __ ]
stands up to that
yeah he's right yeah it's an interesting
time for sure
yeah yeah that's the culture yeah i love
bill birdman
he's great she's one of the real ones
what did she say does anyone know what
she said oh she
yeah he was just she was making jokes
though like no she's
not jokes not jokes no not that oh
it was absolutely she compared to what
the government was doing to covet to
the holocaust and she was like there's
similarities like they start with this
they take away this right like we've
seen this over history
and people have made those comparisons
but she posted an actual picture
i think you will use you know poor taste
and probably not the smartest thing to
do but lose your
job over it dude yeah and then what's
interesting is the the
the co-host on that on that same
mandalorian show
years prior made us uh something a
similar
comment and he's fine no one [ __ ] with
them but just because she did it during
right now
she got cancelled damn so it's crazy
[ __ ] that show's great too yeah she
actually came out and said that uh
somebody over in disney accidentally
sent her an email saying that they want
to fire her anyways
this is what me and brian were talking
about so what she did i don't
vouch for it i love gina i think she's a
great human being
and i think it's totally [ __ ] up what
they did to her but uh
i think it was a matter of they're just
waiting to get ready yeah
that's why as soon as they saw us like
yes we got her who knows maybe they want
somebody else for the role maybe she
wasn't
what they thought it was in a fit who
knows but usually
those those studios those networks you
know like
they're going to stand behind so like if
that's daniel day lewis or leonardo
dicaprio i think he'd get fired over
that true
no true shut the [ __ ] up because it's so
talented with her they might have had
someone else in mind for the role
yeah they were just waiting for a little
crack like oh there we go she's out
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah how
about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just read a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son